[Applause]
okay we're back on the internet uh we
are yes we are how many levels of this
show are there oh
that's but here's a question for you
that they asked what is what is the
toughest thing about being labeled
Hollywood's nicest
comedian just stupid jerks who want to
talk to you all the
time
okay uh roua how has traveling or living
outside the Middle East changed your
perspective on the area where you grew
up it changed it a lot actually because
I I realized that leaders do you live in
America I do oh you do I do and I
everybody likes America everybody votes
well I lived also in Europe for a long
time but what in intrigued me about this
country that the PE the question that
people asked and one day when the people
start asking the question why should be
why should we be paying taxes without
representation from that you have the
most eloquent idea which is Declaration
of independent and one day citizen asked
herself why should I be sitting in this
side of the bus and from that you have
civil right movement and the election of
great president that teach the rest of
the world how to be fair and good to
your minorities and this is why I take
back home and I hope we will be
different with our minorities because
this we we do have a lot of problems but
we are a self-editing Edition aren't we
I mean
does someh great ideas great ideas if
you think about Frederick Douglas and
the way when he said you know a struggle
is actually must be a struggle because
power never concede anything without
demand no and people can actually like H
Bill might you know favor freedom but in
the end they profess to favor freedom
but in the end they actually deprecate
agitation it's like people that wants
rain without Thunders or wants oceans
without the many Waters these people
that stink or that
stink and I think a struggle I know that
you sometimes we complain about struggle
but it must be a struggle because it can
be moral or physical but it must be a
struggle we did have 700,000 men died
resolving the conflict over slavery so
it wasn't like it was a smooth
transition where we are today and the
Constitution took seven years to be
mostly from disease mostly from disease
most of the most of the deaths in Civil
War were from disease
it's from from would did you hear that
that's a that's a fact isn't that true
that is true and and just because the
two of you agreed no
no so far around that no I agree too Bob
okay Marty that does it looks like you
lost it was a denter you know it was
yeah and they had hookers that's how you
got hookers what happened and general
hookers the general hookers follow 3
seconds that's how hookers came to be
it's more than three seconds right
here's a question here's a question for
you Mr Troublemaker have we reached a
point where the threat of a full-on
assault by tea party money is enough to
discourage candidates from seeking
election I guess they're asking this of
you because the person who defeated you
in Nebraska was one of Sarah Palin's
Grizzlies was she not yeah I don't think
so man I think you've got a problem with
people just not wanting to run
regardless of whether they're getting
whacked from the left or whack from the
right it can be unpleasant so you know
the big question is whether or not
citizens are willing to cross line from
being a private person where you you
know other than the government's right
to you know Google you and find out what
your what Your Cod is a flaming liberal
I mean you're a Democrat you're a
progressive but you were a veteran you
fought for this country what can a guy
like you ever win in
Nebraska well it's hard imagine a guy
like me win in anyway if you really you
don't really know me I mean that's the
problem if you really know me not like
not like McCain and and Lindy Graham
certainly I I don't you know well no
there's a lot of things that went into
me losing besides just the tea party I
mean I spent 10 years in New York and
that was the probably the biggest and
most difficult but the the big is they
held that against you wouldn't
you really you oh Bob car went to New
York oh yeah no no liberal New York so
remember right after 911 they liked New
York they did yeah I forgot that fast
dick Luger didn't really live in Indiana
that sort of slowed him down in this
election as well oh really where did he
live he lived in Washington yeah he had
a he had a post office box or something
right yeah people want you to live in
the state you represent that's the same
same thing a lot a lot of Hollywood
stars say they live in exotic places you
know Johnny Depp lives in France and you
know they all live here they all live in
they all live in Beverly Hills
they all they do they all live in here
what uh Michelle what has big business
done to show that they can be trusted
should the deregulation you Advocate
occur what a great question yes but they
can be try what what has big business
done to show that they can be trusted
should the deregulation you Advocate
occur big business business in general
in America is is the greatest provider
of jobs do answer the question trusted I
in in terms of what I mean well I think
they mean that when they were let when
the regulations were let go starting
with Clinton getting rid of glass Eagle
they pretty much Ted the economy glast
Eagle would not have prevented any of
the big failures not a single one I've
heard a different opinion on that that
okay I could list them but let's not do
that Banking and the oil industry are
the most regulated Industries in America
that doesn't mean that that well I don't
know if that's true and even if it is it
doesn't mean and I can point to several
regulations which would have actually
helped cause the crisis like when
Regulators say Mortgage Debt is better
so if you have a lot of Mortgage Debt at
your bank you don't have to have as many
reserves against it so what Banks do
they gobble up Mortgage Debt they say
you know what governments don't default
so when you have government debt on your
books it's okay you don't have to
reserve any money against it and so they
gobble up government debt and then you
know what government's default so you're
saying the crash of 2008 would have been
eded with less
regulation yes a absolutely just all
right well that's that's out of the
box that's way out of the box we like
that on our show we don't want be in the
Box you're not in the
Box caus by human
nature human nature exactly that's and
you know what that's why capitalism is
the right system because you have to go
by human nature communism was wrong
because it tried to make the river flow
in the wrong direction you have to use
human Nature's selfishness but that
flowing river does need dams and locks
on it because if it's just let go then
then you'll have flood planes you got to
sort of control the river a little
I I agree blow it in the right
direction if I just could Senator Cary
knows this the problem is we we needed
regulations for these unregulated things
these bundles where you owned this
week's mortgage payment and you own the
interest on the mortgage and so forth
and so on but what happens is Washington
tends to kill ants with sledgehammers
and so you get a bunch of regulations
that are stupid that are actually
counterproductive you really don't get
to the problem some of them that's right
you don't get to the problem okay thank
you every every buddy we're going to let
you go we'll see you next week Real Time
with Bill Mah Friday night at 10: ask
Bill and his guests your questions right
after the show at hbo.com